[Music]
this is a keepers union and noticed
something in the sky a giant meteor
heading straight for us
I'm asking you goalkeepers to save ours
I have an idea
meet the Gonski mega [ __ ]
also known as baldra it's coming laughs
do it for us and it's right beneath the
time Oh scheisse what happens when 800
of the world's most elite footballers
and their managers live together under
one roof play a stop being polite and
start getting real this is the champions
[Music]
yeah yeah I get it
we just got to take it one match at a
time I suppose now girl right look I
guess this is a little worse than normal
[Music]
this was supposed to be our yeah now the
world is ending
hi yes oh my prayers have been answered
Kevin don't you see everything is
destroyed men City would be the last
team to ever win the Premier League
title can I get a little help here
I can't do this by myself oh man I just
got my braces off Paige is crazier than
I thought
oh oh thank goodness there you are my
precious little Yankee boy I thought to
be accepted at Chelsea I'd have to do
all these British things it turns out
all I had to do was score a bunch of
goals come on get in we'll get you to
safety
where would you take us back to your
house it's still standing
I'd rather take my chances all right
suit yourselves
all rise at the wheel don't pop the bus
ah
I don't see what everyone is complaining
about yeah it's like a home game
please let me a please defeat at all my
botox is melting it's the air worse in
here I haven't seen a disaster this bad
since I played for FC Pompey that's
nothing I used to play for Arsenal yeah
what was that oh my stomach I'm 12
minutes overdue for my fourth protein
meal it's okay we have a year supply of
non-perishable foods here Benzema looks
like all the food is gone you know what
this means it's okay to eat people
so should we head back we can't go back
we blew it will be a bunch of Laura
scary asses down there
Hey look attention keepers up the
champion me and Claire after review by
galactic power we have determined that
during the build-up of the meteor a dust
particle was outside the meteor strike
is disallowed
[Music]
[Music]
everything is back to normal
yes haha well back at the top of the
table a stupid collected far I guess
we're going to have to do it the
old-fashioned way
winning 18 matches you know must be nice
it's okay I am here now and remember
good always be worse whole years before
that happens and by then you'll be
longer Hey look the Champions League
mansion went back to normal when do we
get to reset back to normal
unfortunately Phil I think this is the
new normal
[Applause]
[Music]
this cartoon it is the special one of
cartoons
so park your bus right here and show
your respect by subscribing